with necessary death how many film
festivals did you travel to and also in
choosing those film festivals how you
know critical for you of them and
screaming like
that's a swirl with their audience count
but I've got this book with ultimate
film Testament Survival Guide Chris who
are I think in its blue edition and we
just sent to the top ten there was it
like a very handy list didn't even have
to read the book it was just a list of
the top festivals in the world and I'm
lazy so I just thought that sent to
those festivals um
in South by Southwest was coming up and
I know idea about festivals at the time
but South by Southwest was fire
underneath and we got into that and it
became we were very lucky that way you
know we screamed there and there was a
lot of controversy because we're still
at all is it real is it not real the
trailer had been put online people were
outraged even before that seen the movie
but the movie completely sold out all
three screenings and became this thing
from there and
we went to a Phi Fest which I also was
really surprised that we got into the
very cautious inviting alumni of
navigate by conservatory because they
don't want to be seen you know as doing
favors to their own people
and we got into that and we won the
Audience Award which is incredible on
paper because we suddenly like with the
role of audience Awards at AFI now is
Hotel Ronda diving bell and butterfly
and necessary death you know you know
where our or life as beautiful as on the
other so we're on this list with these
incredible movies that have won Oscars
and our movie no one has ever heard of
but it's actually if you are if you're
thinking about wishes we screened in a
tiny tiny theater and in our own
hometown so our audience was our friends
so they're voting for the movie they're
probably voting more favorably than they
then your neutral audience would and so
then it's easier to win an audience at
work that way I don't know but we wanted
and and people really cared
Asians care managers care you know
suddenly wasn't everyone's later and it
didn't matter how we wanted or whatever
it was just like because maybe one day
if I
audience award and then we went to a
couple of smaller festivals Calgary and
some in Norway that were really fun and
really had an effect on the audience but
did we do anything for the knife
you